welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
vos and El Camino the breaking bad movie
following Jesse Pinkman after his escape
from the series finale released a new
trailer that gives us several big clues
about what this mysterious film could be
about now I posted a preview video
breaking down some preliminary details
some theories about how Walter White
might have been able to survive the
Breaking Bad finale and slightly less
crazy how Breaking Bad could be set in
the same universe as the Walking Dead go
check that out here I'm gonna break down
this trailer shot by shot along with
some other footage from two teasers that
were released because this is Vince
Gilligan here folks
Skye packs more detail and symbolism
into two minutes then Game of Thrones
did in an hour of king branches hollow
stares set so much with so little
spoiler warning for all of Breaking Bad
and for any predictions I make about El
Camino that might be too accurate and
ruin your life let's get started okay
the trailer opens with Albuquerque
police charging past Jesse's El Camino
pulled over to the curb as he waits in
the passenger's seat with a gun ready
now this would be moments after his
escape from Jack's compound following
Walter White's shootout in the Breaking
Bad finale jesse stumbles up to the door
of his old buddies skinny Pete last seen
with badger pointing lasers at Elliot
and Gretchen for Walt to scare the crap
out of him I love that skank Pete is a
trampoline of course he does got to spin
that drug money on something and he
might notice that this whole film is
being shot in a 2.40 aspect ratio' Vince
Gilligan said that he was able to get a
much bigger budget for this film which
includes shooting it with the same lens
that they shot movies like the revenant
in so the result is essentially a
Breaking Bad epilogue with even more
cinematic visuals and production value
not bad for a character who's supposed
to be killed off in the first season
moving on
okay skinny Pete looks shocked to see
Jessie like he barely recognizes a guy
or can't believe that he's still alive
now the first teaser released for El
Camino showed skinny Pete in an
interrogation room with DEA agents
asking about Jesse's whereabouts
Simon watching the news same as
everybody else I see that little cage is
they kept in there I heard about what
all they did didn't make sure he kept
cooking finding the more recent teaser
scene that was released news actually
did not include specific details about
the shooting that the infamous
Heisenberg was there or that it was at
the compound where most of the blue meth
of the Southwest was being cooked by the
way a neo-nazi gang that imprisoned
Jesse to cook for them horrific scene
with multiple victims
it started when neighbors reported
hearing hundreds of gunshots fired when
Albuquerque police arrived they
discovered the bodies of nine male
victims oh and by the way if you go back
to count in the Breaking Bad finale
scene those nine victims are Todd Jack
Kenny and gang members Matt Lester
Franklin the other dude first seen in
the adjustable chair in the guard at the
gates who was outside at the time of the
shooting that makes eight plus Walt nine
so sorry if you're one of the conspiracy
theorists who believe that Walt somehow
survived the final episode and yeah I do
include part of myself in that because I
definitely entertained the notion but
I'm still going on hope that blue meth
created the Walking Dead zombies anyway
the fact that those details were left
out of the news unless more reports that
come out with more details that might be
how these interrogators catch skinny
Pete in a lie let's move on
that's the way
these things go
so mine okay we got to talk about the
music here this track is called black
water by Ruben in the dark from their
funeral sky album the songs composition
is that of a church hymn with organ
instrumentals and in the lyrics
allusions to baptism redemption
cleansing oneself of guilt and break sea
mortality and interestingly Jesse's
return here if you think about it is
definitely striking some parallels with
the return of Jesus in the New Testament
post resurrection and I'm not just
talking about Jesse Christ's beard and
shaggy hair here though those are
helping his body is covered in scars
just like Jesus's body from his
scourging Jesse like Jesus is known for
his extreme suffering being the ultimate
scapegoat and having an innately
peaceful soul that gets taken advantage
of by demonic temptations and after his
supposed death
this criminal seemingly resurrects to
his former disciples who stare at him
and disbelief like doubting Thomases
badger even takes off his beanie as if
to show a kind of reverence so I think
the intent here is to reframe the events
of Breaking Bad from a cautionary tale
about the tragic fall of a morally
bankrupt devil to a tale of resurrection
and redemption of a suffering Christ
figure who still has unfinished business
on to the next clip
No
I changed
here Jessie showers off the grime of
which there's a lot of it and the lyrics
of the song friend this moment has a
deeper cleansing of the soul washing
away the guilt of his slavery for Jack's
gang and restoring himself to a more
active and complete hero I like the
detail of Jessie braaap the gun with him
into the shower as if he was so out of
it they didn't realize he was still
clutching it although he probably still
feels pretty paranoid and then secure
like at any moment his freedom could
still be snatched away from him again
and let's not forget this is a world
where meth cooks are at constant risk of
getting offed while they're in the
middle showers next clip
[Music]
okay after Jesse cleans up and heads
back into the world there's a quick shot
familiar location this is the river
where Walt shot Mike
in season five actually if you look
closely at the two figures standing
there that appears to be Mike actually
joining Jesse those two cars in the
background are Mike's New Yorker and
Jesse's old red Toyota Tercel and
Jonathan banks did confirm at the Emmys
that he would return in this film but
based on their cars I'm guessing this is
a flashback like maybe this is an old
meeting place of Mike's and he showed it
to Jesse some past moment may be hiding
something there for Jesse to find if he
was ever in a tough spot then we see a
picture of Andrea and Brock that Todd
pinned up in the meth lab who threatened
Jesse into cooking for Jack's gang and
the background appears that police are
still examining this crime scene
maybe they notice this photo as a clue
for Jesse might be headed next moving on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in this section there's a shot of the El
Camino as it travels through the New
Mexico desert now notice that the back
canopy has been pulled over where in
other shots the back of the car was
opened up suggesting now that Jesse
might be carrying some cargo may be
planning to sleep in it for a long trip
but actually in the teaser scene that
was released at the very end in the
rearview mirror reflection and can
almost make out something or someone
moving in the back of the El Camino
behind Jesse now of course it's not
clear whether this wide shot takes place
after Jesse's escape or while he's still
with Jack's gang because the next shot
shows him digging in the desert with the
same clothes and hairstyle that he had
while a prisoner in the Breaking Bad
final episode he appears to be digging a
grave because in the foreground that
looks like human hair from corpse
wrapped up in a rug that he intends to
bury now my depressing guess is that
this could be Andrea whom they forced
Jesse to watch Todd murder and now
perhaps to add even more insult to
injury jesse has to dig her grave and
bury her in the white shot of the hills
there appears to be someone standing
beside Jesse could be Todd or Kenny
another member of Jack's gang make sure
he does the deed and before I move on
there's a shot of Jesse looking for
something in an old house I thought that
might be the old white family home that
won't revisited in season 5 episode 9
after had been ransacked by vandals but
the carpet and fixtures look pretty
different let me know where you think
this is let's move on
[Music]
[Music]
so okay here there are some time-lapse
shots of Albuquerque and shots of
Jesse's sneaking around a neighborhood
but then amazing a deliberate callback
with Jesse in this beetle this is a nod
back to the moment in season two the
amazing peekaboo episode which opened
with Jesse meeting with skinny Pete and
briefly touching this beetle by his feet
it was a moment that revealed Jesse's
inner gentle spirit which always made
murder such an earth-shattering thing
for him by contrast when skinny Pete
walks up immediately crushed the beetle
without fought throughout the Breaking
Bad series bugs often had some greater
thematic significance like this beetle
foreshadowed the death later that
episode with the meth-head spooge
getting crushed by the ATM then famously
in season 3 there was a fly representing
Walt's paranoia over contamination and a
metaphorical fly and Walt's pointment of
his relationship with Jesse with Walt's
guilt over Jane poisoning their
partnership then in season 5 there was a
tarantula caught by the boy who
witnessed their train heist whom Todd
murdered and just like the tarantula the
boy's body was later stuffed in a
container and throughout season five
Walt covers up his cooking by doing it
and pest extermination tents reflecting
how he was efficiently killing off his
competition so by returning to this
beetle moment el camino' appears to be
reminding us of that peacefulness inside
Jesse before he was sucked into Walt
darkness there's also a point of view
shot on a crane magnet to a scrapyard
perhaps the one owned by old Joe who
crushed the RV into a cube for Walt and
Jesse there's a shot of someone maybe
Joe in the office seen a news report of
Jesse Bruce Pinkman perhaps Jesse will
need to go back through his junkyard to
find something that might have been left
inside the RV before it got crushed
whatever Jesse's looking for it looks as
though it's taken him back through his
memory lane of his story arc throughout
Breaking Bad working with Mike this time
with Andrea disposing of evidence with
Walt etc etc next clip
okay Jesse now wearing skinny beats be
nice nice through some residential
complex beside him the room block topped
with police caution tape that's more
shots showed Jesse using a lighter to
search this messy room and then shots of
tanks of chemicals emitting a flame
perhaps being set up to explode maybe
Jesse went back to Jack's lab to torch
the place destroying the evidence that
he might have left behind and there are
more shots of police and crime scene
suggesting that El Camino will continue
the whole cat mouse game of Breaking Bad
maybe Jesse as the one survivor of the
crime scene at Jack's compound will be
the suspect that the cops pin all these
deaths on this guy cannot catch a break
let's move on to this final clip you
ready
okay this is the big mystery of the
trailer who is the mystery man in the
gunslinger pose bass and Jessie asking
you ready boys doesn't sound too much
like Walter White others are saying it
could sound a bit like Edie
Robert foresters character the vacuum
repair guy who makes people disappear
for the right price
but then again Jessi missed his chance
to disappear and you ready doesn't
really sound like Ed to me however if
you remember Mike Ehrmantraut once said
you ready right before killing one of
his co-workers in season five are you
ready
Mike but I want to know from you guys do
you think Jessi is ready to die here and
who do you think he's talking to comment
down below with your thoughts hit that
like button and subscribe to new rock
stars for breakdowns of everything you
love follow me on instagram and twitter
at EA boss thank you for watching and
Jesse's gotta be talking to Bill burr
there right and it's gotta be him sounds
just like him
[Music]